Brad status stars ben stiller as a
father who's going through a bit of a
midlife crisis she's taking his son to
various interviews at colleges that he's
hoping to get into he's really hoping he
can get into Harvard but he's not sure
while he's doing all of this he's trying
to connect with his son because he feels
like this might be the last trip that he
can take as father and son before his
son goes off to college and he doesn't
get those opportunities anymore but at
the same time he's having a bit of a
nervous breakdown he's thinking about
his friends his very successful friends
who have all gone farther in the
business world than he has and he's
beginning to feel like his life might be
a failure he's not sure the direction he
wants to take and this movie is a
meditative look at a man with those
feelings
I'm actually a big fan of Ben Stiller I
think that when he's given the right
role something like Meet the Parents or
the original Zoolander which is a big
guilty pleasure for me flirting with
disaster there's something about Mary
while we're young when he commits he can
do an excellent job and I think Brad's
status might be his best performance
he's very very good here very
understated this film does rely a lot on
narration which for some is a major
issue it's never really bothered me when
it's used correctly I say correctly
sometimes movies use it purely as an
expositional mouthpiece and it makes no
real sense for the story but films like
American Psycho for instance they use it
great and so does this film you really
get an insight into the trauma that he's
experiencing in his mind and also the
paranoia because I think most people
know especially if you deal with any
form of anxiety or depression that you
often make everything that you're
worried about bigger in your mind and it
really needs to be and this film
definitely explores that when it comes
to Brad's character he's got everything
that he's afraid about at the same time
though you're looking at someone who has
a wife who loves him a son who loves him
who might get into Harvard a nice house
and while he doesn't make a lot of money
he owns a respectable non profit
business and you might be thinking dude
shut up you don't have anything to worry
about in fact a character in this film
says that to him
so it explores not just how we can take
problems in our mind and
I'm up to this epic proportion they
don't have to be it also shows how to
other people that's viewed as highly
arrogant and so it doesn't shy away from
the fact that people who have issues
have issues but sometimes those issues
aren't really founded in anything
concrete but that's just how you feel
so it's kind of riveting actually to
watch him go through these mental
mousies having with himself as he tries
to figure out what his kids going to do
and what his wife wants to do but at the
same time it feels like in his brain his
world is creating this environment of
problems that maybe don't even exist I
really enjoyed watching that I thought
that it was a unique approach to a film
that you may have seen before
where someone's going through a nervous
breakdown of some kind this film had a
way of going about it that just felt
more real than others the performances
are all uniformly excellent and Mike
white who directed and wrote it wrote
some really snappy dialogue his
direction is mostly handheld and it
doesn't really feel like it has much of
an energy to it but that's sort of this
film's goal I think it's trying to be a
film that you can kind of sit back and
experience purely from the character
perspective it's more about the
characters and less about the director
showing you a movie it's just more about
filming these people in this environment
and letting us know what they're
thinking and feeling this film is mostly
a drama but there's a fair amount of
humor as well sometimes those jokes can
hit and miss not everything lands
perfectly there's a few scenes that feel
elongated more than they need to be
there's a bar scene I think it went on
too long but for the most part I had a
blast watching this movie I thought it
was a perfect fall movie it feels crisp
the shots look crisp everyone's wearing
coats it just seems like the perfect
movie for fall that really explores some
interesting characters in ways that I
didn't expect I'm gonna give Brad status
and a minus
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I hope you check out this film
if it's playing near you as always if
you liked this you can click right here
and get steppen eyes
[Music]